pope francis has harshly criticized
europe for what he says is the
exploitation of migrants for political
purposes the pontiff was speaking during
his visit to a migrant camp on the greek
island of lesbos the island is a main
entry point for migrants from africa and
the middle east seeking asylum in europe
[Music]
a warm welcome for the pontiff as he
greets hundreds of migrants here on
lesbos
[Music]
he condemned the situation on the island
calling it a shipwreck of civilization
with deep regret we must admit that this
country like others
continues to be hard-pressed
and that in europe there are those who
persist in treating the problem
as if it doesn't concern them
this is tragic
he criticized the global attitude
towards and treatment of asylum seekers
it's easy to stir a public opinion by
instilling fear of others
yet why do we fail to speak up about the
exploitation of the poor
the remote causes of migration should be
attacked not the poor people who pay the
consequences and are even used for
political propaganda
just over 2 000 migrants live in the
camps here
a fraction of the numbers that crowded
the island just two years ago
but still there is little shelter from
the cold and strict restrictions on
people's movements
the pope's visit sparks hope for those
enduring these bleak conditions
and he came to visit us and not only
like hearing it from far but he came to
the field to see how we live to see how
things happen here so it's it's give us
hope and strength knowing that such a
leader thinking about us and coming to
visit us
pope francis has consistently warned
countries against turning their backs on
migrants and ignoring their plight
those here on lesbos are hoping his
message might finally now be heard
and in recent months the shortfalls of
eu's border policy have been brought
sharply into focus by belarus that's
where thousands of migrants have arrived
hoping to cross into eu member poland
brussels says the belarusian government
created the crisis by alluring the
migrants with false promises but some
say poland and the eu are ignoring human
suffering dwe's alexander fonnaman
reports
searching deep in the forest for people
in need of help as temperatures drop
well below freezing by night
a resident from a local village brought
us to a spot just outside the exclusion
zone where migrants were camping earlier
that day
people are dying
bodies are being found in the forest
but nobody talks about that
not long ago a friend saw a body by the
side of the road
he says he's ashamed and angry with the
way the government has been handling the
situation a storehouse a few kilometers
away the arta is one of many volunteers
trying to help
she tells me the migrants she meets in
the woods have been pushed back into
belarus multiple times
they want to warm up at least for a
moment they want to shave wash
themselves
they ask us whether there's a house
where they can hide or sleep for a bit
unfortunately
we cannot give them that
is particularly disappointed with the
role the european union is playing in
this crisis
my impression is that the european union
supports poland by giving them their
blessing for
but that's what's been happening in
poland the government changed the law to
legalize pushbacks officials argue the
current situation requires changes to
long-standing practices
the international asylum regulations and
in particular the geneva convention were
written in the 1950s
long before we had to deal with what
alexander lukashenko is doing
to send off criticism authorities have
promised more transparency although they
formally lifted the state of emergency
last week restrictions remain in place
no one without a special permit is
allowed to access the area the situation
at the polish border with belarus seems
to have calmed down a bit in recent days
apparently the number of migrants in the
area has decreased at least for now but
the border zone stays off limits for
visitors including journalists with
security forces on high alert
authorities don't seem to be willing to
open up the area anytime soon even
though humanitarian organizations are
raising the alarm as conditions in the
woods get worse every day